[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est le premier jour du
printemps de bourge dont on fête les 41
ans je suis sur la place sours là où le
printemps propose une programmation
gratuite au festivalier j'ai décidé de
vous faire partager mes coups de cœur
mes rencontes avec les artistes je vais
vous emmener aussi dans les coulisses du
festival allez suivez-moi là on est au
dernier moment derniers instants du
printemps de bourge dernier préparatif
aussi et du coup on va aller voir à la
boutique comment ça se passe on va les
aider à installer
aussi bonjour bonjour bonjour Alors on a
besoin de d'aide ou pas et ben alors
jeune fille on y va bah oui j'arrive je
vous suis moi qu'est-ce qu'il faut que
je mette en place moi simple est-ce que
je vais y arriver
est-ce que je vais y arriver cette année
c'est Pierre Janot qui est à l'origine
du visuel du festival un éventail de
couleur et de forme mêlée pour
représenter la diversité musicale voilà
comment le printemps a décidé de
renouveler son image c'est quoi tout ça
j'ai que des j'ai un
XL faut que je referme tout ça bien
quand même he que ça soit beau propre
mais c'est un peu la dernière ligne
droite avant l'ouverture de toute façon
là la présentation 14h donc là dernière
dernière présentation et après on
avantin bon comme je les ai un peu
installé ces casquettes j'ai décidé d'en
piquer une donc attends faut voir déjà
que comment ça s'installe ce truc je
pense qu'elle me va très bien c'est
idéal pour commencer un festival
maintenant j'y
[Musique]
vais premier jour du printemps la tête
d'affiche attendue c'est Renault et sa
première partie un petit jeune qui
devient dragran à seulement 22 ans team
DP ouvre le festival à quelques heures
du concert il semble pourtant détendu
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être le premier
artiste auow en première partie de
Renault c'est génial trop bien bah à la
fois d'ouvrir pour le printemps de
bourge et devant autant de personnes
donc c'est une belle opportunité de
chanter les chansons de mon EPÉ et puis
quelques-unes de mon album à venir et et
puis Renault bah voilà c'est c'est la
classe d'ouvrir et puis en plus c'est
amusant mais il y a 39 ans bah il y a un
jeune artiste qui jouit ici pour la
première fois et c'est Renaud et comment
ça t'est venu l'écriture parce que tu as
une écriture quand même particulière mes
parents m'ont ouvert à l'art à la
culture à la musique et après et après
je pense que ce type d'écriture là il
m'est aussi venu en écoutant du hiph hop
et justement avec cette idée d'une
urgence des textes et et de spontanéité
d'écrire ce qu'on voit et ce qu'on pense
comme on le dit en fait et voilà de lier
à la fois un peu de poésie et de et
de de coucher les mots de manière un peu
brute bah voilà il y a plus qu'à
[Musique]
hein je vais ici et
là jouer de mon piano dans des soirée au
fil de
[Musique]
l'eau qu'est-ce que la vie des gens
sinon celle dont il rêve enfant et moi
j'ai toujours voulu devenir
ramur
souvenir c'est parti on va partir en
patrouille allez allez on avant marche
quatre cavaliers de la brigade équestre
sécurisent le festival habitués au stade
et au parc ils sont venus des iveline et
de la Haute Marne pour une mission
plutôt
[Applaudissements]
originale comment ça se passe avec le
public mais justement l'avantage avec le
public c'est que on a il voient le
cheval d'abord le cavalier et en dernier
la tenue police donc du coup on a un
super rapport avec les gens en général
ouais ça se passe bien est-ce que c'est
justement un peu sympa aussi pour vous
ce ce genre d'événement devenir un
festival photo on est applaudi parfois
même c'est quand même la police c'est
assez rare quand même donc du coup c'est
vrai qu'on a une image un petit peu
différente par rapport aux gens les
enfants enfin tout le monde voyez les
gens ils s'arrêtent pr c'est quand même
plus sympathique à pied c'est quand même
assez rare qu'on soit pr en et comment
il s'appelle le appelle bambou voilà
c'est une première pour lui il a 5 ans
on le travaille toutes les semaines à la
désensibilisation drapeau fontaine
plaque d'égoutût gobelet par terre
bouteille en plastique et là il découve
tout d'un coup en fait tu me reniaques
pas bonne continuation auir au
revoir et nous maintenant on va se
préoccuper du printemps dans les bars
vous allez voir ça Swing Swing dans les
rues de Bourges
[Musique]
age c'est la rencontre de trois garçons
pour une musique électrop le groupe
berichon avait participé à une formation
à la scène en janvier dernier exercice
pratique ce
soir comment ce plis TR petits cochons
c'est un des Bar qui bouge plus au print
de bourge on est est assez content de
jouer là
il y a pas mal de monde ça ferme tard et
quand on parle à des gens du printemps
de bourge même des gens de la France
entière souent il nous parle de ce bar
là c'est un des Bar qui revient le plus
en fait dans la mémoire des gens dans
les conversations c'est toujours
intéressant aussi d'être programmé
pendant le printemps de bourge vous
pensez qu'il y a une meilleure
visibilité c'est quand même plus
attractif la chance de jouer dans notre
ville et d'être vu par des gens qui ne
sont pas forcément de la ville après on
est un peu noyé dans
une groupe il joue sur le même soir mais
bon c'est quand même cette chance là
quoi d'être sur place et de pouvoir être
vu par des gens qui sont pas forcément
ou c'est quand même une bonne
vitrine merci on est
cage une première soirée bien fraîche
pourtant réchauffée par les notes de
musique et un public
[Musique]
con
belle ambiance sur les scène gratuite du
printemps cette année le soleil est au
rendez-vous et les équipes de bénévoles
du Secours populaire aussi ils vendent
un badge lumineux à l'eigie du printemps
la petite trouvaille de l'édition
2017 bonour monsieur je profil du
Secours populaire il est clignotant non
non merci bon bonjour messieurs bonjour
Alors c'est un badge au profit du
Secours populaire qui clignote dans la
nuit qui a 2 € je vais vous en prendre
je vais aller chercher ma femme qui a
l'argent là-bas je suis avec Boris Vedel
directeur du printemps de bourge
pourquoi avoir eu cette petite idée du
badge clignotant on chercher quelque
chose qui puisse un petit peu fédérer
les gens du Brinton debourgge le donner
un petit peu un sentiment d'appartenance
et après on s'est pas arrêté là parce
qu'on voulait quand même le faire à
notre sauce et on y a à collé on appelle
on y a collé une action RSE
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
c'est une action solidaire donc c'est
que c'est 2 € mais les 2 € ils sont
versé au au Secours populaire la
totalité des 2 € pas la totalité des 2 €
en fait puisquil faut fabriquer le badge
donc encore une fois qu'on a enlevé ce
ce ce coup de fabrication tous les
bénéfices sont reversés le printemps
touche absolument aucun centime
là-dessus c'est très important non c'est
juste pour fédérer les gens et en même
temps voilà aider des publics peut-être
moins favorisé que d'autres très très
important en parler parce que c'est la
première année mais il aura plein
d'autres merci
[Musique]
merci originaire de Grenoble ces CIN
garçons ont le métal dans la peau ce
soir il joue sur la grande scène
gratuite de ses recours une
[Musique]
première c'est assez inédit en fait au
printemps de bourge avoir une scène
métal métal qui assez inédit comment
vous vous le percevez en fait c'est bien
c'est pas bien comment tu veux faire
c'est une fierté un peu ENF c'est une
ouverture d'esprit qui commence à se
faire c'est plutôt intéressant
donc on est une qui mérite de s'ouvrir
aussi au plus grand public parce qu'il y
a des gens qui connaissent pas ou qu' on
peut-être des a priori et on espère que
par ce BIA là justement un festival
comme le printemps de bourgge qui a
quand même déjà une bonne renommée va
permettre aux gens de d'avoir cette
accessibilité au métal quoi oui parce
que pour le grand public le métal
c'est des de la batterie des guitares un
peu saturées et on crie dans dans le
micro vous vous en avez un peu Mar qu'on
vous dis ça j'imagine
[Rires]
ensess faire essaie de le faire
proprement juste en étant juste bah pour
un public non averti c'est vrai que
c'est perçu comme ça mais après il faut
s'y pencher un peu plus ce qui va
ressortir en premier ça va être le champ
la batterie et après il faut tendre un
peu plus l'oreille et trouver les
mélodies ce genre de chos et c'est là
que ça devient intéressant
justement le printemps de bourge c'est
de l'électro du rock de la pop mais
c'est aussi du rap et je vous emmène à
la Halle au
blé rénové l'année dernière la halle du
marché accueille désormais la scène rap
du printemps une programmation pointue
avec Kie James et des petits nouveaux
comme Aladin 135 l'uréa des inoui en
2016 Lorenz débarque la merde ça cach ta
baron va
fum va
[Musique]
frère retour au
W après le concert de Placebo il faut
bien manger un peu et il y a le choix
moi je F déguster un r à
taille j'ai un super chapeau je suis
équipée ça y est je fais partie de
l'équipe
c'est officiel comment on anticipe les
quantités dans un festival il y a des
journées un peu des soirées plus grosses
que d'autres notamment demain bah bien
sûr bah déjà aujourd'hui par rapport à
hier et avanthier en fait bah déjà en
fonction VO en fonction des concerts
bien sûr savoir s'il va y avoir des
entractes ou quoi que ce soit tu vois
déjà quand les gens arrivent quand les
gens arrivent on sait que quand on voit
les gens courir pour aller au concert
ceux qui courent pour être devant et
ceux qui courent pour être en premier
ici et et voilà et donc nous on par
rapport aux horaires des concerts on
sait on a déjà on fait déjà d'énormes
cours sur les produits secs ce qui pas
les d non périssable évidemment une
organ moi je vous prendre ça en fait pas
de taille s bon ouis mais oua
ou allez N et samous et samousa c'est
parti moi la journée se termine ici je
vais finir ce plat de pâte et je vous
dis à
demain ce matin je me suis réveillé un
peu plus tôt que prévu je vais à la
rencontre des équipes de nettoy du
printemps parce que c'est aussi ça les
coulisses d'un
festival là on a surtout des affiches à
enlever on a du du décapage à faire par
exemple ce matin rue Moyenne il y a eu
des pots de peinture de renversé donc il
y a une équipe de décapage exprès qui
est venu exprès pour pour tout nettoyer
ça le but c'est qu'à 8h avant que les
voitures ils arrivent et que les gens il
vont au travail il faut absolument que
que ça soit propre ça soit nickel quoi
vous avez des petites anecdotes à nous
raconter parce que comme vous commencez
votre service à 4h du matin souvent vous
croisez les derniers
festivaliers souvent souvent les
derniers bon on voit que c'est les
derniers quoi parce que ils ont bon ils
ont ils sont ils ont des têtes fatiguées
on va dire ils ont des têtes fatigué
puis nous des fois ils veulent qu'on les
ramène chez eux ils veulent monter dans
le camion ils veulent bon ils nous
demandent plein de renseignements et ça
qu'il a la troué verte qu' a le camping
donc bon alors mais généralement ça se
passe très bien on essaie de leur faire
comprendre qu'on peut pas les emmener et
puis voilà quoi et siôt nettoyé siôt
remis parce que le festival continue au
3è jour du printemps nous avons eu le
privilège d'assister aux répétitions de
la création en hommage à Barbara un
casting 100% masculin dirigé par le
pianiste classique Alexandre tarot avec
en invité surprise Julien
CLA
[Musique]
de tout âge et de divers horizons les
hommes choisit l'ont été aussi pour leur
amour de la grande dame et de ses textes
[Musique]
intemporel je pense qu'elle a pas besoin
de de vivre elle est là elle pas besoin
qu'on la fasse vivre elle est là moi
Barbara c'est par égoïste parce que
j'aime la jouer et aussi j'aime la faire
partager par d'autres par d'autres voix
par d'autres harmonies par des par voilà
c'est sans fin touche à des thèmes qui
sont
très qui sont le mal-être le mal de
vivre le qui qui on on une résonance
forte chez chez des jeunes gens et et
puis pas que chez des jeunes gens mais
c'est c'est c'est des je pense que c'est
ce qui fait son répertoire continue à à
exister
[Musique]
si
sold
[Musique]
siarop les anges avec leur trompette la
jouront jouront pour toi cette petite
contate que nous jouons autre fois les
anges avec leur trompette la jourons
jourons pour toi cette petite cantate
qui monte vers toi 6000 AR 6000 AR si
sold au FEM 6000 AR si000 AR si
sol
si000
[Musique]
au même moment la file d'attente
s'allonge devant le palais JAC cœur les
spectateurs sont impatients de découvrir
la lecture chantée de Delphine de Vigan
et de la Grande Sophie un spectacle
entre littérature et
chanson c'est disciplines TR hybrid et
nous on est pour les passerelles on a
voulu créer cette passerelle on adore ça
c'est très enrichissant pour nous donc
on se dit que pour les autres également
mais ça correspond aussi à l'histoire du
spectacle qui est d'abord une espèce
d'histoire de de de solitude on est
chacune on se regarde pas au début on
est un peu comme chacune dans son monde
en fait et puis il y a le moment qui est
d'ailleurs pour nous sur scène est
souvent un moment de soulagement où on
commence à interagir et où souvent les
spectateurs nous disent oui bah nous
aussi on est content quand ça se produit
il fallait qu'on crée ce lien bien
entendu il est important
voilà donc c'est c'est aussi voilà on
est séparé sur scène au début et puis
tout d'un coup quelque chose se
passe quand j'étais petite ma mère
déposait un ou deux carrés de chocolat
sur une tranche de pain elle la glissait
dans le four j'attendais derrière la
vitre je regardais le chocolat fondre
passer de la forme solide à la forme
molle c'est ce qui me plaisait le plus
assister à cette métamorphose
on avait les cheveux longs des dents de
lait et pourtant on savait on savait que
ça n'allait pas durer on chassait les
papillons on posait plein de questions
on savait on savait que ça n'allait pas
durer on collectionnait les billes on
sentait bon la vanille on savait on
savait que ça n'allait pas durer on
était toujours jaloux et on attrapé des
pou on savait on savait que ça n'allait
pas
[Musique]
durer qui
aurait pu nous le
[Musique]
dire
ce matin j'ai rendez-vous avec Floriant
touselier directeur artistique d'un
fameux label son travail pendant le
printemps de bourge c'est de des talents
et potentiellement de signer des
contrats il profite des inouis pour
faire son marché il y a une vraie partie
découverte il y a quand même un
dispositif des inoui qui permet de
mettre en avant la scène locale
française et et ça c'est non négligeable
en tout cas pour pour pour tous les gens
du métier de la musique de de se réunir
et de de de se rendre compte de
qu'est-ce qu'il y a en France et la
richesse qu'il y a en France au niveau
musique la plupart des groupes les
connait un petit peu déjà parce qu'on on
s'est déjà renseigné et que et que c'est
assez rare d'arriver sans vraiment
connaître la
programmation après ça permet des fois
d'avoir des bonnes surprises
donc un groupe qui fait bien parler ou
qui réussit son son printemps de bourge
et ben peut peut-être derrière avoir des
rendez-vous plus des dates et donc c'est
c'est un vrai marchpied donc ça permet
de de de se rendre compte du niveau en
fait de de de l'artiste une HE avant
l'ouverture des portes les festivaliers
sont déjà là au palais d'Oron le
régisseur de la salle briefe ses équipes
pour les gilets oranges la mission de ce
soir est d'accueillir le public dans les
meilleures conditions pour thba ça fait
10 ans que ça dure 10 ans qu'il vient
travailler au printemps de
bourge c'est un travail mais également
quelque chose de de festif pardon
vraiment un grand rassemblement
populaire et pour lequel on échange
beaucoup les gens sont là pour découvrir
les gens sont là pour s'amuser il y a il
y a vraiment
de quoi faire au printemps de bourge que
ce soit aussi en ville il y a vraiment
tout un tout un
phénomène de retrouvaille c'est ça
surtout ça c'est un rassemblement c'est
ça que j'aime beaucoup ce soir il va
falloir réguler le flux des festivaliers
entre le palais d'Oron et le W la
mission de Thib c'est de surveiller le
public pour qu'il ne passe pas dans les
loges tout est prêt pour le Happy Friday
une soirée pour faire bouger les cors et
réchauffer les âmesim musque de calyp
rose la doyenne de la
[Musique]
programmation j'ai commencé à écrire à
13 ans et je suis monté sur scène à 15
ans et maintenant j'ai 76 ans le 27
avril j'aurais 77 ans donc je ne peux
pas m'arrêter la musique est dans mes
veines et c'est tout ce que je
suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je viens à
bourge je pense que c'est l'occasion
d'essayer de comprendre
Bour c'est une bonne chose que j'apporte
ce genre de musique dans le centre de la
France au cœur de la
France je suis heureuse d'être
[Musique]
ici
direction la cathédrale pour une tout
autre ambiance un concert de musique
classique avec les sœurs Julie et
Camille Bertolet à moins de 20 ans elles
ont réussi à envoûter le public de
bourge
[Musique]
le printemps de bourge se termine ici
pour moi au pied de la cathédrale
j'espère que vous avez passé une
excellente soirée en notre compagnie je
tiens à remercier tout particulièrement
l'équipe technique qui m'a accompagné
sur cette aventure si vous désirez
revoir cette émission elle est
disponible sur le site Internet de
France 3 cent et sur Youtube passer une
excellente soirée sur France
[Musique]